well citizens of the reject Nation if
you've been following this journey here
I left town because getting married and
then John and Coy took over for a day
and then uh I zoomed in with John for a
couple of videos and then the day John
was leaving to come to join the wedding
party because we have to go to a wedding
party event right after this yep and
John just landed in Colorado it's great
to be here like two hours ago it's a
lovely uh coloradian Studio you've got
here now we got a Barbie trailer and I'm
like oh let's just whip it out dude why
not we're crazy enough so Yep this is
another just unedited reaction video
today
knock one off your Christmas video bingo
card for contest I don't know why I'm
excited for it I am I know why I'm
excited for it everyone is involved
why co-writer Noah bound box uh yeah um
let's see what the trailer has to offer
John I want man let's go too and then
let's go
there have been dolls
but the dolls were always and forever
baby dolls
until
[Music]
foreign
this is perfect
yeah I mean it looks great
margolith
this is the best Barbie commercial of
all time I don't care what the movie's
about
wow fascinating
yes yes
it's very tough that is an Issa Ray I
think right
wait what
that's right I heard C moves in this
movie
oh yeah okay so he must be playing one
of the other Ken's oh my goodness okay
well that was I'm not the first look I
was expecting at all no but I I kind of
love it though you gotta you okay I have
I've seen that scene from 2001 A Space
because so many of my favorite
filmmakers talk about 2001 A Space
Odyssey so I've seen that scene and
people like talk about why it's like one
of the best scenes in cinematic it's a
pretty great scene
um but I actually haven't seen the movie
2001 Space honestly so I wasn't
expecting to start off with that because
I did hear like some potential plots for
what this movie might be about I don't
know if you've caught it yet but I don't
know a couple of things and little bits
and pieces it's still just it's a rumor
really is that basically there's like
Ken's and Barbies that live in a Barbie
world and then the Barbie that we follow
is going to be plastic and fantastic
she's gonna be setting out to they gotta
play they gotta play yeah Aqua has to do
the soundtrack let's go party this is
the one opportunities for like Aqua has
to do the whole soundtrack well then
eventually she Ventures oh you get
through this John I can do this this is
what happens when you're uncut it's it's
these moments all right all right
and redo the word video they're living
in the Barbie world so lives in a Barbie
world and I heard that uh like they
venture out into the real world then uh
and and it's and that the Mattel CEO is
played by Will Ferrell and there was
like a Set photo of Will Ferrell he's
basically trying to bring them back
yeah it was funny because it is like a
Lego Movie kind of thing right yeah it's
absolutely or an elf kind of story in a
way of a fish out of water who's like
has a certain way of living in a society
yeah yeah and then Ventures into the
real world and and I don't know learns
some lessons I guess about I don't know
why they they move that's what I can't
figure out because I've heard two
different rumors about like one is that
she for being an imperfect Barbie She's
kicked out or another one is that um
yeah they just Ken wants to venture to
the real world
I heard that and then this opens with
2001 Space honesty which John what is
your interpretation of why they would
open with this I love this because it is
like the best Barbie commercial of all
time and it helped me to the idea that
okay regardless of what the plot of this
movie actually is the people making it
are having a good amount of uh
well-informed fun with it because yeah
Barbie Revolution I you know it was the
next big wave I'm not the expert was it
like the first big doll and not the
first big doll because I feel like you
have American Girl and things that
precede that and that's partly what
you're seeing here is like you know
you're seeing the older School doll
being yes you know used as the weapon
instead of the bone they're smashing
their old dolls and they are basking in
the glory of you know this ineffable
futuristic doll that is Barbie She's the
monolith of toys that's what I mean like
the first of her of her kind to be such
a revolution because she's arguably the
biggest doll of all time yeah well yeah
to this day probably still the biggest
doll ever sure I mean she's she's like
Mickey Mouse she's a cultural icon and
that's the thing is I I appreciate it so
much deeper of an opening than one would
anticipate because it's because I mean
it feels like spoof but also meaningful
no totally yeah yeah it's absolutely
silly but also it is a representation of
of you know in a cinematic way what
Barbie did to the doll you know world at
the time and also it's just like a
cinnamon nerd thing to do and so for me
coming into this this kind of checks all
boxes and I feel like there could be
like a a Stepford Wives element that
maybe is not on display here I think it
was a little darker I imagine sure yeah
because you know Barbie also has to grow
and uh you know adapt with the times and
you know Barbie has also been an icon
well she's broke Barbie but Barbie has
always been like perfect John perfect
wouldn't change the thing about her the
perfect boss every woman should aspire
to look like Barbie in every man should
decide to look like Ken always plain and
simple
that's the message at the end of this
being a smoothie it's not some
deconstruction of what Barbie represents
in world and conflicts with today's
society I want to critical awaken to
pull a password I want Greta go you guys
all Gotta Get Fit and look be blonde do
it Botox yeah yeah buy a pink Corvette
this is perfection yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is the one lifestyle this is the
elite and this is the we are the gold
standard well I love Ryan Gosling's cat
I mean whoever knows me knows I'm I'm
especially obsessed with Ryan Goss sure
I have like I'm talking like a real
everyone's like I'm obsessed oh my God
I'm like I know I you're gonna buy
candle why I would and that's I would
buy the Kendall you would the thing is
proudly and I think Margot Robbie is
arguably
she's arguably the best actress today
I mean she like I said about someone
else recently though like and probably
that exact same Cadence yeah and I can
almost hear it might have been I feel
like it's Margot Robbie though she does
because she's still like a she's still a
movie star Tarantino yeah yeah yeah well
that's what he makes it only works in
movies but that's the thing is yeah no
she she is she is perfect for Barbie
because obviously she's gorgeous and in
a very uh conventional not to be mean
but yeah
sort of way and uh but also yeah she has
hella chops and she's really uh you know
sharp in general and she seems like the
perfect person because Barbie you know
is a conscientious lady all right she
has a million jobs she does all sorts of
things she's a boss [ __ ] but it also
looks really like a maybe the Barbie
film one might sort of want with having
a Barbie land and then seeing the
variations of different kinds of Ken's
and Barbies because it also feels like a
a real comedy yeah no it does yeah like
an artsy comedy like a real take well
yeah because you're going that one shot
where you're seeing over her shoulder
into the rest of Barbie world you know
it feels like you're in some kind of
hopped up 60s movie or something like
that but it's so garish because of
obviously the Barbie Aesthetics yeah uh
but yeah like it looks like it has a lot
of that zazz but could have that Lego
Movie level of sort of meta but also
emotional commentary on the whole thing
and what Barbie means not only as a toy
icon but also for people who played with
Barbara you know coming at this as a boy
at the time you're like I play with
action figures they can for us exactly
for us thank you
absolutely that's why Ryan Gosling is
here because they know he's gonna pull
us in uh but yeah like we gotta go to
the wedding party we do have to go these
are our last thoughts John yeah I don't
know I like the trailer do you like I
like the trailer a lot and uh and I I
was cautiously optimistic and this looks
like so much fun and I'm here for it
yeah I really feel like we could talk
forever about this though this looks
this looks like the best possible
outcome because you hear who's involved
and you're like that's kind of weird but
also that'll be some Cinemas do you hear
like Greta no first you hear Barbie yeah
and then you're like okay and then you
hear Mario go Robbie and you're like all
right right
more than just like is this a funny or
die sketch a good credit you're like so
it's gonna be like a meaningful Barbie
movie yeah what this is so strange can
we get one Aaron Paul Ken that's all I
want but then Wilfred I don't know she
might surprise us this might just be a
pure comedy like a pure zany comedy I
feel like it could because I think we're
all expecting Greta Gerwig you know
Pursuit Lady Bird in no pocket yeah he's
like oh it's like a fairly Brothers
movie no I feel like it has to have a
certain level of like Snappy comedy and
wit to it but I feel like it could
probably remain funny even if it's
getting a little darker edgy at times
you know I feel like uh this could check
all quadrants man yeah this could be a
four quadrant
do you feel like your body is perfect
leave your thoughts down below uh be
sure to subscribe leave a like we talked
much longer than they gave us a lot
comes out the other side man Barbie's
Trailblazer how could this not be
greater discussion about Barbie how
could this not be great in this random
Airbnb the Barbie movie had better be
Dynamite outrageous qualities but I'm
sure than it already was no we have the
Barbie channel now every Barbie Barbie
[Music]